this is one of the greatest imax
theaters around it's also the apex of
Los Angeles and here in downtown LA so
it was a great place to launch the film
you know it's the story of the universe
of galaxies for me black holes dark
matter it's thrilling it's big and it's
loud and it couldn't be anywhere but an
imax screen we try and take people
places they dream about going to but
probably will never get to and to be
able to give audience as an opportunity
to do that through the vision of
world-class filmmaker like Terrence
Malick is what our medium is all about
no one does big immersive experience
you're like Terry it's been lovingly
designed with imax in mind the unique
thing about voyage of time is it has
both the educational you know side to it
but also the creative side the artistic
side and the inspirational side you can
get lost in a movie that's this
cosmically big and brad pitt's narration
allows you to kind of move down the line
and be able to thank some very deep
things his voiceover is not only
educational but also very emotional it
makes it very experiential you feel in
the journey and on the journey it's a
movie that I think will definitely
appeal to everyone there's a lot of
strong science in it but there's also
just a lot of amazing visuals that let
you see how the world has been created
and it's a really beautiful phone I hope
that you know watching voyage of time
will make you fall in love with our
planet
you